[Music]  my fellow bros  my fellow brethren my fellow comrades  the time has come for us to fight  back no more will we become embraced  by mainstream media no more  will i take this online abuse and hatred  no more will i say i'm sorry  i missed up okay and you know why  i'm number one i'm number one no more  lane boxing matches  i challenge t-series into a saber fight  like real men i'm throwing my glove at  you t-series  fight me irl to the death no boxing  glove and helmets i'm talking about to  the death here  if they want to accept my sword  challenge then the only thing we can do  is fight fire with fire  smash sub subscribe smash  subscribe smash subscribe  smash subscribe what are we gonna do  smash subscribe that's right  you